bientôt c'est squeeze vous savez ce
qu'on fait quand on est fatigué qu'on a
un vilain rhume et bonjour un jeu
d'horreur voilà il aucune logique dans
cette phrase ces partis aujourd'hui on
est sur une biche paille tu prends ça se
dit et c'est un jeu où finalement on
doit veiller sur ce petit être humain
appelé bébé voilà juste là on peut le
prendre carrément regarder elle arrête
de pleurer en plus c'est bien et si on
leur met je suis fatigué j'ai envie de
dormir c'est pas loin d'entendre avait
crié non vous êtes d'accord avec moi à
l'entreposage pour faire ça c'est toi
c'est toi avec ta maman avec moi
peut-être c'est peut-être quoi ta maman
finalement ou alors je suis juste une
caméra volante dans un jeu vidéo
normalement l'histoire c'est [ __ ] mais
à tort mais c'est quoi ces parts ont
collé des photos demeure muet partout le
tapis de bain s'il faut de leur bébé
le rideau de douche photo leur bébé
alors l'histoire voilà c'est cette
[ __ ] de fumée noire qui veut posséder
le bébé voilà ce genre de fumée qui
chassent un peu le bébé elle a attiré
par les cris du bébé quand je prends
dans mes bras elle ne crie plus donc la
fumée sinval et ouais tu t'arrêtes ses
petits amis ce moment là du coup tout va
bien avec nous avons là ok ça le piège
du coup quand je lis dans mes bras elle
pleure plus mais par contre je peux plus
interagir avec le décor comment je bouge
toi non fumée noire non tu es toi je
peux poser par terre ou pas ce bébé au
non [ __ ] j'aurais tellement aimé la
sur le tapis comme ça en plus il s'en
fout il dort quoi jusqu'à preuve du
contraire regardez ça ça dort dans un
lit sur un tapis on s'en fout ils
s'adorent ok je galère un peu ado mais
ça me fout la pression quoi pourtant
l'ennemi fait qu'un homme aperçu de la
fumée noire mais elle fait quoi fumée
noire elle doit celle de demain à paris
tel quel ou bien le fameux rideau de
douche sur lequel on peut trouver des
photos de ce bébé
bon alors attendez mais murray c'est
quoi ces paroles gaga sérieusement au
podium et ses deux fils de tom cruise
[ __ ] regardez comme il lui ressemble
on va pas lui dire on peut dire ça va
peut-être le vexer il va peut-être
encore plus crier dans son [ __ ] de
lits mais bon on arrête s'il te plaît
arrête hockey ton ps pas tom cruise
c'est le bradley comment es-tu de la
famille j'espère que tu ne perds pas
trop d'heures de sommeil à cause du
petit bébé que nous y dort pas mais nous
à supporter quand même le peb ok c'est
intéressant et j'en peux plus des cris
de cet enfant j'en peux plus une clé
bouge on cherche une clé interrupteur il
ya un disque est pas du tout tais toi
foetus mêmes disent que l'ordinateur n'a
plus de batterie et une batterie de
rechange ou un câble ou encore une photo
de ce [ __ ] bébé j'en peux plus il va
me hanter cette nuit tous à des
cauchemars avec ce bébé qui pleure comme
ça
ou ce tableau de chiens colorées ses
salles interrupteur c'est pas ça ça
s'est ouvert mon gars juste le temps de
descendre et remonter les matchs sur à
la fumée noire assez casse un vrai
casse-tête bordel est une branche se
transpercent maudit bébé et peut-être
plusieurs berceau à un dans chaque pièce
par exemple ça nous ferait plaisir en la
regardant on peut peut-être mettre
là-dedans il est dense un peu plus tôt
on va le donner à manger à quelqu'un est
bien un truc oh oh oh oui cachette il
est dans mes bras et il ne pleure plus
soit pas d'aig
vous avez vu on a rigolé fumée noire on
a une vie passionnante quand même moment
à blaye et petites notes mon gars
o'neill la clé 2 et dans le code donc
dans le coffre jusqu'au attendait parce
que la gestion les explications mais
regardez regardez là comme elle est
forcée de fumer là elle est un peu
passive à la fumée pas fourbe finances
ouabane aig
mais pourquoi ce bébé écrit comme ça
mais c'est insupportable pourtant ils
s'appellent tous avec certes été un de
dormir posément c'est une boîte à meuh
mais nouvelle génération pas pu leur
tourne tu leur prends pour passer sa
tendre et par un démon pareil hockey où
elle charger de l'ordinateur dans le feu
la cacher oh mon dieu c'est ses parents
regardez ils n'étaient pas encore nés
élevés jamais dû naître ce [ __ ]
d'enfants alors le chargeur il est là je
peux transporter et le chargeur et le
bébé voilà voire même électrocuté le
bébé avec le chargeur ça se tente
et ça c'est quoi c'est le grand frère de
ce bébé qui sert qu'au niveau de sa tête
eut un problème mais bon s'il est moins
chiant moi je préfère m'occuper lui
vraiment j'en peux plus de ce bébé j'ai
envie de le jeter la donne dans le sapin
comme ça se fera une guirlande de
nouvelles générations regardent ces
papas et mamans quotidien oui oh oui
respect de l'autre côté du mur joue plus
jamais voir des parents qui doit
abandonner mon chargé de m'occuper de
toi pendant que tu kiffes leur vie aia
les atours d'un nouvel enfant il tour
trail t des gains un petit cause c'est
peut-être pour ça que tu pleures autant
finalement à bah oui ça explique tout
comment je vais à charger son ordinateur
l'actuel juste à cliquer oui
ac c'est quoi ça c'est bon what my à
l'affût mais qu'arrive non non non non
non trois fois non
un swap à l'aide à l'oignon retourne
alors le code du coffre
dis moi tout m'énervait la chaurienne
déplace à deux sièges
c'est quoi le password route non échappe
à tous les noms mais sort mec non non
non sort du pc comment il s'appelle cas
il se fait sur l'ordi avec la vue sur le
clavier cui plus partie était scotché
tâche est en train de réussir je suis
parce qu'on est fatigué ok on se calme
quand il s'appelle ce bébé ya pas son
[ __ ] de nom c'est peut-être sur la
note
ok fait donc confiance on va mener l
enquête disparition je suis père
célibataire sans enfant désormais qui va
me pêcheront j'avoue j'ai un enfant mais
vraiment millions à tétouan à tétouan ok
en à charger on doit reprendre le colis
jamais le collier à l'état je répète
collier à l'état je reçois pas
d'expliquer ce qui amène le bébé comme
ça tu es d'aig t dégâts à mais je te
loft chaque fois je comprends le little
one radelet ok je pas trouvé comme celle
ci est du genre tu te retournes windows
non ça fait perdre et au torino à mon pc
appuyé pour recommencer
tu me dis comment tu t'appelles et je te
sauve de la grande méchante fumée hockey
puisque commencent par un s ça parce
qu'il ya un mais cela tu vas finir dans
cette armoire était au courant de ça
comment il s'appelle ah mais je sais
attention à ce que pour la première fois
deux oreilles mais je vous ai
impressionné sur un jeu vidéo tout
sahara voilà ce [ __ ] bébé s'appelle
sarah le mot de passe sera sarah aller
et qui se charger fou sur les quais
pourquoi il ya sa trace quoi comme s'il
avait transpiré le chargeur sur la table
non attention soyez fiers de moi dans
trois haletant qui s'allument le temps
qui salue à la fois
bah oui windows 95 je pète un câble je
te le dis jamais tu es le top cruise
c'est bon au revoir sarah sfc quoi c ou
c ou qu'est ce qui se passe quoi
s'efface 49 91
comment je quitte comment je quitte ya
bien une touche pour quitter ce pc non
non
on attend maintenant les ramène mon bébé
mais qu'est ce que tu fais mon gars a en
fait c'était moi c'était moi le vilain
mais c'est nous real et s'est même
déplacé super stressant avec que
personne ne nous critiquent sont au
talent de baby sitter ok on m'a volé
jean bravo nous sommes des héros on a
quand même bien veiller sur ce bébé qui
pour le coup nous faisait vraiment chier
c'est elle ou la vie j'espère que ça
vous a plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude
j'adore tester les jeux indépendants
d'horreur comme ça que je trouve qu'ils
sont super original mais elles se sont
pas forcément hyper beau gosse
pratiquement j'espère que ça vous plaît
aussi même si pour beaucoup cela était
assez court d'un se retrouve bientôt
dans deux vidéos peut-être plus longue
peut-être plus courte
peut-être buvant de l'eau des marais
partie mais ça va regarder la vidéo je
propose qu'on ait tout de suite se faire
une saison tous ensemble là dans le lit
le plus grand du monde
ciao du monde pis
elle